pas
janvier 2015 courbevoie dans les
hauts-de-seine
un homme est un coup de pied dans les
pratiques de la grande distribution
élu municipal arash derambarsh récupère
à la fermeture d'un supermarché
ce qui part normalement à la poubelle
pour leur distribuer immédiatement
salade
c'est comme si vous ou l'un porte quel
citoyen à les acheter en fait dans un
supermarché à 20h30 et consommer des
aliments périmés dans quelques heures
emballages animée autant de produits
encore consommables mais que les
supermarchés n'ont plus le droit de
vendre mais rien ne les oblige à les
donner aux associations pour la salade
un sujet qui révoltent cet élu de 36 ans
qui part alors en croisade médiatique
ils démarchent des stars court les
plateaux télévisés et lancent une
pétition pour obtenir une loi qui
imposerait le don des invendus des
supermarchés pour dire stop au gâchis
alimentaire
rejoignez est signé la pétition signée
la vision plus de 200000 personnes vont
la signer fort de ce soutien populaire
arash derambarsh contacter les
politiques et au sénat c'est nathalie
goulet sénatrice u 10 u c'est de l'orne
qui s'empare du sujet j'ai suivi sa
campagne magnétique schwab à commande
quelqu'un aurait pu l'éviter surtout sur
twitter où il est omniprésent et en fait
j'ai vu j'avais noté que frédéric
lefebvre a déposé un amendement dans la
loi macro et donc j'ai décidé de faire
la même chose à l'article 10 et
je n'ai déposés et je les fait adopter
vous avez des supermarchés qui tous les
soirs jette
d'où la nourriture comestibles et qui de
surcroît verse dans les poubelles de
l'eau de javel pour être sûr que
personne puisse venir le récupérer
cesser ces procédés sont absolument
insupportables
heureusement la société civile ne nous a
pas attendu mes chers collègues
ça fait belle lurette que ça se fait ici
et là je pense préférable que cette
proposition de loi qui est en cours de
travail qui viendra dans l'est dans les
prochains mois devant la haute assemblée
me semble un cadre plus approprié pour
traiter de ce sujet tout en partageant
l'ensemble des préoccupations qui ont
été ici rappeler par l'un et l'autre
d'entre vous qui est pour cet amendement
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement est voté à l'unanimité je
vous remercie
votée au sénat mais non retenue dont le
texte final de l'assemblée nationale
l'amendement est à nouveau adopté dans
le texte sur la transition énergétique
avant l'été mais le conseil
constitutionnel le rejette pour des
raisons de procédure
ségolène royal s'empare alors de ce
sujet populaire et médiatique le
gaspillage suite avec le coup de
pression de ségolène royal à la grande
distribution la ministre a convoqué tout
à l'heure les principales enseignes pour
signer des engagements notamment celui
de ne pas détruire les invendus des
distributeurs ne peuvent délibérément
rendre leurs invendus alimentaire encore
consommable impropre à la consommation
les enseignes s'engagent sur le papier
pas convaincu les parlementaires
décident de poursuivre leur travail et
déposent une proposition de loi au sénat
comme à l'assemblée
pas question pour eux de s'en tenir aux
bonnes paroles
sur le terrain dans l'orne nathalie
goulet est venu voir comment cela se
passe avec la banque alimentaire
une des dix huit associations agréées
pour collecter les invendus de la grande
distribution dans ce supermarché on n'a
pas attendu d'y être obligé pour donner
aux associations
cela se pratique depuis des zen
expliquez moi un peu la répartition des
produits dont 40 tonnes dans l'année
c'est énorme et ça se divisant
ce que la banque alimentaire n'est plus
père au quotidien des produits qui sont
un peu défraîchi mais qu'ils sont
à la base on les aurait enlevées du
rayon donc les enlever les jeux la
poubelle ou alors les mettre à
disposition de la banque alimentaire
pour nous il n'y a aucune perte de temps
et si ça peut faire profiter des gens
principal s'il y avait une voie qui
passerait
je pense que ça pourrait permettre tout
est encore davantage
mais en tout cas nous saluent magasin
fonctionne déjà très bien comme ça
et la convertit si c'est joli mais moi
je t'ai mieux donner
merci de votre accueil avec plaisir
une fois le camion chargé c'est au local
de l'association que s'opère la deuxième
étape de la collecte avec des règles
bien définies
quand ça vient là on a une forme de tri
donc tout ce qui est fragile a étrillé
la qualité au niveau date au niveau
température avec les directement commune
et ses rails sans frais jusqu'à la
livraison cette production n'a pas droit
de tous et qui est mixé découper cette
erreur n'a pas donné les légendes à
chier chaîne du froid respecter
bénévoles formés aux règles d'hygiène et
de sécurité
la banque alimentaire assure aussi une
traçabilité des produits en cas d'alerté
sanitaire alors forcément l'initiative
d'arâches derambarsh suscite des
interrogations
il a donné sans se soucier vraiment des
problèmes de sécurité alimentaire à lui
il a dit c'est des produits c'est le
coeur qui a parlé bon c'était très bien
mais il faut aussi savoir que quand on
donne on à la responsable mais le diable
se loge j'aurais détails oui bon messani
est super important parce qu'en fait on
reçoit tous les jours
les alertes alimentaire les grands
distributeurs donc il faut qu'on sache
où ces partis nous ont étonnés qu'ils
prenaient directement qui prend son
cabas équivalent donné alors il n'y a
pas de traçabilité
c'est pas jouable ça
cette banque alimentaire collecte 58
tonnes par an auprès de la grande
distribution
l'équivalent de 30 mille repas la loi
obligerait toutes les surfaces de plus
de 400 mètres carrés a donné un
changement énorme pour les associations
si la question est est ce que cette loi
est une ou obligatoire pour que ça
marche
la réponse est probablement non ça veut
dire que bon faut qu'on soit plus
musclée au niveau bénévoles plus musclée
au niveau au niveau camion il ya une
logistique à mettre en place qui n'est
pas celle qu'on connaît actuellement
qu'il faudra probablement augmenter qui
font rares en ce cas retravailler quoi
pour nous je dis bien que pour nous
banque alimentaire de l'ordre ça marche
bien donc en fait la crainte que j'ai
exprimés c'est que c'est un équilibre
très fragile et je voudrais comme tous
les équilibres et gevrey qui reste quand
vous quand vous quand vous insérez de la
contrainte
voilà où les choses se passent bien ça
braque les gens payent dans un équilibre
difficile à trouver
même les associations sont divisés les
banques alimentaires comme les restos du
coeur sont plutôt défavorables à une loi
alors qu action contre la faim comme la
croix-rouge soutiennent cette initiative
inspirée par arash derambarsh lui ne
souhaite pas opposer les différentes
démarches
c'est complètement complémentaires ce
que je propose par rapport aux restos du
coeur à la banque alimentaire ou à
toutes les associations agréées qui
peuvent stocker la nourriture
je rappelle que les restos du coeur et
la banque alimentaire font des collectes
toute l'année au même moment les
enseignes jette tout de même 40 à 50 kg
ce sont des kilos ce sont une quantité
incompressibles que toutes les enseignes
jette tous les soirs c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu en faire une loi
les supermarchés qui jetterait tout
l'espoir des denrées encore consommables
faux répond la grande distribution qui
estiment faire beaucoup dans ce domaine
depuis des années on se préoccupe
localement de trouver un moyen pour que
ces produits qu'on ne peut plus
commercialisés ne soit pas fuir et
bêtement je t'aimais trouve une deuxième
vie une réutilisation possible des bons
élèves il en existe en effet
propriétaire de trois supermarchés dans
le nord thomas peau chers et parfois
surnommé le gérant vert depuis des
années il a mis en oeuvre une politique
de lutte contre le gaspillage à tous les
niveaux de ces établissements
à commencer par le rayon fruits et
légumes tomates la plus moche de la
caisse cette petite imperfection là elle
va faire que cette somme est contre les
autres dans la tête et quand il ne
restera pas beaucoup ça va remplacer
celle de commettre à une nouvelle barre
au risque de la disqualifier n'a posé de
côté donc aujourd'hui mais elle va faire
partie de mon petit panier peut-être
saison que qu'on va constituer là et on
va pouvoir retrouver ce genre de choses
et voilà c'est un poivrot alors c'est
vrai que si vous les présenter comme ça
tout le monde achète un vent qui est
parfait alors sa ronde vraiment en
cuisine
bon ben voilà aujourd'hui on leur
propose là il se retrouve avec un
bouquet de persil n'y en a eu il ya plus
de fruits sur des gros volumes comme les
tomates pour la à côté de nous c'est le
métal très joli ça peut représenter
jusqu'à 10% au gaspillage
chaque jour ces 150 à 200 kilos de
fruits et légumes retirés du rayon pour
leurrer à chancy ge signifie qu'on va
retrouver mes premiers fonds a vu tout à
l'heure et qui sont proposés à petit
prix au même titre qu'on va proposer ici
des bananes tu rompu en aspe idéal mais
on va les proposer à tout petit prix oui
c'est 30 centimes et quand
ici c'est récupération à tous les rayons
en boulangerie les invendus de la veille
servent à fabriquer du pudding maison
les légumes vont te dans les soupes et
les fruits sont transformés en boisson à
l'arrière du magasin pour leur donner
une deuxième vie
rien ne se perd tout se transforme on
peut battre tout revalorisé comme on
fait ici ou là on redonne beaucoup de
valeur aux produits qui est venu
plusieurs euros du kilo en général sous
cette forme transformé on va aussi
rendre dans les cagettes qu on
confectionne directement réunion et
qu'on revend 3-0 les cinq kilos donc en
remixant tout ça ont réussi à retraiter
à ne pas envoyer en valorisation
énergétique à peu près 80% des besoins
de produits organiques sur l'ensemble du
magasin du rayon frais à la viande en
passant par des emballages d'épicerie
abîmée tout n'est pas réutilisable
c'est cette marchandise qui sera destiné
aux dons qui n'arrive qu'en bout de
chaîne et représente tout de même de
grosses quantités
tous les jours des associations passe
pour la collecte des amendes on a un
espace de tri et de sélection qui initie
entre des produits qui doivent être
jetés sont identifiés comme tels par les
collaborateurs mis d'un côté et
l'immense majorité des produits à peu
près 90% de ce qu'on veut si c'est pour
des raisons cosmétiques dans les fruits
et légumes on l'a vu quitte à leur tour
le pense c'est une question de fraîcheur
théorique remet sa dispo à titre gratuit
des associations qui veulent nous
rencontrer et les autres produits
les français notamment par exemple à ces
produits là ça c'est du jambon qui était
en promotion pour le voyez une offre
promotionnelle est que l'eau de cas plus
de trente gratuite l'adapter au 21 c'est
plus dans ma charte fraîcheur s'est mis
à dispo dans cette zone des associations
une pratique volontaire mais aussi
encouragés par une belle incitation
fiscale un crédit d'impôt qui fonctionne
comme celui pour les particuliers qui
font des dons aux associations
caritatives sur le don à 90 heures on
semble redécouvrir ce qu'ils appellent
la loi coluche une forme où on permet à
une entreprise de faire de dons en
nature et je me retrouve aujourd'hui
honoré de pouvoir de mai plus de 120
tonnes de marchandises par an dans cette
entreprise
c'est donc 66 % la valeur de mes dont ça
va représenter jusqu'à deux cent mille
euros par an il ya aussi un plafond
était déjà prévu que de 0,5 partout
0 5% du chiffre d'affaires un coup de
pouce censée inciter toutes les
enseignes à s'engager il reste pourtant
du travail à faire
la leçon en oeuvre elles sont déployées
très largement aujourd'hui je peux dire
sans trembler qu'une bonne moitié de mes
collègues dans l'enseignement je fais
partie des clercs ont déployé le même
genre de mécanismes et 95 % des patrons
de magasins sont conscients qu'il va
falloir mettre en place des actions
parce que la communication politique un
peu rattrapé le sujet mais elle a
pendant un tel sujet si les politiques
se sont emparés du sujet c'est bien que
de nombreux magasins ne se sont pas
encore converti à ces bonnes pratiques
21h banlieue lyonnaise les gaspilleurs
ont donné rendez vous ce soir ce
collectif va faire les poubelles des
supermarchés de la région
mais pas comprend pas nos vacances dans
des poubelles c'est pas le meilleur
endroit
by ap
ils s'introduisent en toute illégalité
dans les arrière-cours des magasins de
la grande distribution pour faire leur
marché à leur manière du coup là c'est
un plan ouvrir régulièrement
ouais c'est réglé et du coup on fait ici
c'est super bizarre parce qu'ils trient
tous les aliments et du coup on à la
benne de pain en à labenne devient
l'homme regarde c'est parti pour 15
minutes de récupération avec leurs
propres règles sanitaires
ouais c'est la vienne du jour et tu vois
là par contre c'est gonflé donc c'est
pas bon même si la couleur et les bonnes
saisons tête mais tu vois ça fait sous
vide des crevettes à paul est à mon avis
ça vaut le coup d'être tentée merguez et
sont bien rouge sa dette du 21 donc là
il va falloir faire attention mais
normalement c'est bon et franchement tu
restais même pas que vous faites
monkey dans le raisin le raisin est la
leur à boire à manger de papouilles où
pourtant il est là de que je pense qu'on
va faire un cabas en dessous
et il est nickel voilà c'est typiquement
le type d'aliments frais et des fruits
frais ou on comprend pas du tout
pourquoi ça a été fait mais en fait
quand on fait la récup on se pose
quelques questions
c'est pourquoi ça a été jeté et cissé en
bon état et 6 et comestibles du coup par
exemple les produits ou le packaging il
va être un peu bon fait ça veut dire que
c'est passé mais par exemple ce genre de
raisin on se demande clairement pourquoi
il a été super bon c'est fini
cette nuit-là quatre enseignes de
marques différentes seront visités un
véritable butin est collectée pour une
redistribution le lendemain dans le
centre-ville de lui
13 heures place bellecourt un étal un
peu particulier s'installe habitués et
curieux attendent le lancement de la
distribution non sans écouter le message
des membres du collectif dont nous
préserverons l'anonymat ok les gars hier
soir on a récupéré 300 kg de nourriture
dans trois supermarchés dans la banlieue
lyonnaise
aujourd'hui on se met rue de la ré
change à chaque fois de lieu pour
distribuer toute cette nourriture que si
la vôtre parce que c'est votre classe et
là on l'a distribué gratuitement à tous
et pourquoi à tous parce que les pauvres
en fait ce don past une et c'est pas le
tout pour tourner cette économie de
merde voilà donc en fait vous pouvez y
aller il ya ancrée que la dessert salé
sucré absolument tout je vais tourner
avec les plus petites est ici et
et vous pouvez vous approchez et si vous
n'avez pas ces partis soit l'objectif
c'est quoi ces messages balleux mais
est-ce que c'est aberrant que le
gaspillage alimentaire continue que
malgré les bonnes pratiques soi-disant
des grandes surfaces
et quand même 300 kg dans les poubelles
en h et quatre magasins
on aimerait bien avoir les chiffres du
gaspillage alimentaire pour pouvoir
contrôler cela qu'on dit à tout le monde
comme quoi c'est les consommateurs qui
gaspille plus mais à mon avis ce qu'on a
là c'est quand même beaucoup plus que
chacun d'eux peut gaspiller en une année
on peut se mobiliser contre le
gaspillage alimentaire et faire bouger
les choses du bas avant d'attendre que
les politiques se bouger le fasse pour
nos en fait c'est toute cette nourriture
jetée dont une bonne partie avant la
date de péremption suscite l'indignation
mais c'est une route 25 09
foschi à la moitié de la planète qui a
faim et la manche a pas d'âme de voir
tout ça dans les poubelles scharrach
absolument
l'opération est un succès le stand est
presque vide et le message est passé
la grande distribution en a pris pour
son grade
une loi permettrait-elle d'empêcher ce
grand gaspillage pour s'en rendre compte
direction la belgique et la banlieue de
liège bienvenue à herstal ville de 40000
habitants est pionnière en termes de
lutte anti gaspillage dès 2013 le maire
a imposé le don des invendus des grandes
surfaces
on s'est dit localement nous pouvons
également agir et c'est comme ça qu'on
essaie de trouver une formule pour
pousser la grande distribution a
redistribué les leurs avant que c'est
facile à mettre en place
on est six a toujours pas toujours les
faits il y à de la résistance au
changement aux changements d'habitudes
et notamment au niveau de la grande
distribution
dans cette enseigne on a été volontaire
pour lancer le projet et chaque matin
les mêmes gestes sont répétées donc on
regarde les dates qui ne sont plus
vendable soit ici vous voyez il à la
date du 3 du 10
nous sommes le 30 mai par contre ce
n'est plus vendeur pour pour les clients
donc nous nous retirons de la vente et
nous laisse canon comme ça nous avons
une trace de ce que nous donnons aux
associations et puis nous mettons ça
dans un bac comme avons terminé le rayon
nous allons mettre ça au frais pour
respecter la chaîne de froid vers 9h09
caisse l'association bière on sort les
papiers avec
les articles qui sont imprimés dessus
comme ça ils ont une trace de ce curieux
de ce qu'ils prennent et nous aussi
ici la loi n'a pas changé grand chose
car ce magasin était déjà engagée et
voit désormais plus loin
mais vous savez on le fait depuis depuis
des années des dizaines d'années est
donc pour nous il ya rien qui a changé
on pourrait même aller plus loin on est
carrefour en belgique ne demanderait pas
plus que chaque magasin le fasse que
chaque association puisse en profiter et
qu'on passe par un logiciel au niveau
national où chaque association soit
contrôlé par la sq a bien évidemment par
le gouvernement et que les invendus que
nous mettons à disposition des
associations soient également cherché et
donc redistribuer à ceux qui en ont
besoin
nous ne demandons pas mieux en belgique
pas de crédit d'impôt généreux comme en
france et pourtant tout le monde s'y est
mis
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'en
belgique c'est nous ne faisons pas pour
deux raisons fiscales ou financière en
belgique nous le faisons parce que ça
fait partie de notre politique en
belgique et de carrefour c'est l'anti
gaspille sont les hommes et c'est la
biodiversité et c'est de savoir que
quand on a des produits des invendus
s'il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui peut en
bénéficier
faut le donner à quelqu'un d'autre lieu
le jeter dans cette ville seul un
établissement reçu une amende de 5000
euros et s'est depuis converti aux dons
alimentaires et les autorités sanitaires
ont modifié leurs règles pour favoriser
ces initiatives la traçabilité a
notamment été fortement allégé les
barrières ont été revus pour les banques
alimentaires surtout au niveau de la
traçabilité pour que cette lourdeur
administrative qui est clairement
considéré comme une barrière pour les
entreprises
à juste titre pour des associations
caritatives on ne peut pas passer les
trois quarts de sa journée à remplir des
papiers et bien la sq à lagence en a
tenu compte et a permis par cet arrêté
ministériel et cet assouplissement
spécifique pour les banques alimentaires
a permis la de faire perdurer l'activité
de
d'associations caritatives d'autres
villes belges ont depuis repris cette
idée et le maire d'herstal espèrent
désormais une initiative européenne
on doit viser c'est un élément important
toutes les initiatives dans les
différents pays sont intéressantes et
j'ai eu l'occasion notamment en france
d'avoir un échange d'expériences hôtels
et de participer aussi à une pétition au
niveau international pour essayer de
sensibiliser un maximum de personnes en
france
une commune ne peut pas imposer cette
mesure seule une loi le permettraient
plus d'un mois après l'accord signé par
les enseignes de grande distribution
avec ségolène royal
nous sommes retournés à courbevoie en
compagnie d'arâches derambarsh en caméra
cachée pour voir si les pratiques
avaient bougé dans cette enseigne qui a
trois magasins sur la commune rien
n'avait été mise en place jusqu'au mois
d'août
je fais d'ailleurs voir la
redistribution
mais si on peut trouver un créneau je
viens chercher des roches at elle
appartient tel jour je deviens tu as
quelqu'un sorte de la mairie une
consigne du siège s'est donc imposé dans
une autre en revanche s'ils
n'employaient confié en les mauvaises
pratiques et sa barbe et ses commandes
royales a quand même si on n'a pas
le jeu mais la direction rappellera le
lendemain pour confirmer son refus de
donner pour une redistribution immédiate
et aucune convention n'est encore signé
avec une association l'engagement
volontaire n'étant pas suffisant les
parlementaires examineront un texte dans
les prochains mois qui obligera aux dons
et encadrera la collecte c'est un vrai
sujet je crois que le talent d'arâches
d'aruba jetant dans tout ce dossier
ça a été de rendre extrêmement visible
encore une fois un problème qui touche à
l'éthique au religieux au sacré de la
nourriture extra donc ça nous touche
tous évidemment
donc je crois que c'est un très bon
sujet et donc on est aux confins de la
générosité et d'une vraie plateforme de
gestion avec des bénévoles qui doivent
être formés avec une véritable
logistique et ça on ne peut décemment
pas le laisser entre les mains de
petites associations qui pourraient pas
le faire
un texte qui s'attaquera en fin au
gaspillage de la grande distribution un
secteur essentiel mais responsable de
moins de 10% du phénomène rien
concernant les citoyens qui seraient
pourtant responsable d'environ 70% de ce
gâchis et qui ont un rôle majeur à jouer
dans ce domaine